cheating where were you raised I was
raised in Los Angeles in East Los
Angeles actually Boyle Heights east LA
man so to talk about some of the mindset
that your parents instilled in terms of
work ethic and creativity my parents
were both artists at not successful
artists because we were living in East
LA obviously they weren't that
successful and they had to work at other
day jobs but my father was a
photographer and my mother was a writer
and a songwriter and they gave all their
children there were four of us intense
music lessons and dance lessons for me
and my sister and when I started to show
some ability in theater they encouraged
me to go into the theater and they had
very high standards and we were trained
classically so we were not trained to do
anything uh in the pop vein they looked
down their noses at anything that was
pop-oriented so we all had very
classical training and it it left an
impact on me and you know when I would
do anything that wasn't up to my
mother's standards she would she would
be very very quietly critical and say is
that the best you can do oh ok so the
goals and the standards that were set
for us we're very high and I think
that's why i choose to do these kind of
documentaries that are sort of large in
scope that have a kind of a classical
approach to them that hopefully will
last and have some kind of impact
because of that training that I was
given what did you also witness from
your parents about I guess you'd call it
the artistic struggle in terms of
holding those day jobs but really your
heart
where else well I knew that that the
world was very hard for them it was very
hard because emotionally and
artistically their passions were stilted
by circumstance I mean they had four
children they were they themselves were
products of the depression there their
parents were foreign-born they were
first-generation American both of them
and they I think they felt that part of
what they had to do in life was carve a
better future for their children and
they did that all my brothers and
sisters are all in the arts we have all
sustained ourselves as artists and we're
still trying to prove something to our
parents but we're grateful to them too
you